[Musique]
p3 l'industrie du disque veut taper
parce qu'avec le mp3 le prix d'un disque
peu baissé de 80%
c'est très simple il suffit d'avoir un
ordinateur connecté à internet
vous allez sur un site vous sélectionner
un fichier que vous télécharger sur
votre disque dur
gratuitement le tout sans payer le
moindre droit d'auteur 1993 apparaît le
mp3 parallèlement internat tisse sa
toile et quelques années plus tard le
monde est connecté 1999 apparaît un
programme conçu par trois développeurs
napster désormais le téléchargement
illégal est accessible à tous plus rien
ne sera comme avant
avant 1999 quand tu voulais de la
musique ben tu l'as acheté ou tu trouvé
un copain qui avait le cd original et
ucopia sur un cd vierge à l'aide d'un
graveur bref tu piratait ou alors tu
aller à la fnac
tu acheté le cd tu le grave est chez toi
et tu retourner au magasin pour se faire
rembourser
ouais tu pouvais faire ça à cette époque
si le cd ne te plaisais pas tu pouvais
te le faire rembourser ou éventuellement
les changer ça n'a pas duré très
longtemps
après ils ont arrêté je ne sais pas trop
pourquoi non non je n'ai jamais fait non
non on me l'a raconté c'est tout chaud
net - bref 1999 c'est le début de la
démocratisation du piratage est ce qu'on
peut dire sa démocratisation du piratage
mais il existe une autre forme de
piratage dont vincent est un digne
représentant
il prend ses idées dans les magasins
traditionnels mais jamais plus il ne
leur achètera un disque j'ai connu les
fnac ou sur plusieurs étages il y avait
des kilomètres de rayon disques
je vous parle d'un temps que les moins
de connaître
[Musique]
désolé même très bien je pense que je
vais aller me vallet télécharger larmes
de vincent le mp3 de lettres et un
chiffre qui font trembler l'industrie du
disque mp3 c'est un nouveau format de
compression
il permet de faire passer de la musique
par internet du coup les internautes
s'organisent s'échangent des musiques et
pour se rencontrer et dispose même d'un
supermarché virtuel nom de code napster
c'est une bourse d'échangé international
de de musique par exemple à l'heure
actuelle il ya une pub 1300 personnes
qui sont connectés et qui propose un
total de 106 1000 chansons disponibles
en téléchargement gratuit gratuitement
bien sûr j'ai plus d'une centaine de
réponses sur céline dion elle savait du
premier album au dernier album qu'on
trouve à l'heure actuelle en magasin
donc là je vais lancer le téléchargement
de cette chanson là it's all coming back
ce mec est en train de contourner la loi
pour du céline you et quelques minutes
plus tard dans le même temps vincent a
fait tourner son graveur résultats donc
maintenant qu'il est gravé les jeux le
sort de donc sage est gravé un titre
dessus j'aurais pu graver tout l'album
de céline dion
il aura fallu je télécharge des autres
chansons donc là en l'occurrence jean
les charges et qu'une ensuite je vais
tester sur ma chaine hifi up sur le
disque paye et est ce que ça marche ça
devrait marcher
voilà voilà pourquoi vincent on achète
plus de disque en magasin
coût de l'opération 10 francs le prix du
cd vierge bon il y avait deux écoles de
pirates ceux qui avaient l'adsl ou le
câble des vitesses de téléchargement
assez rapide pour l'époque quatre
minutes pour environ 4 mégas il y avait
les autres ceux qui utilisaient le 56
cas ce n'était pas très rapide comme son
nom l indique le débit descendant était
de 56 kg bits par seconde maximum départ
rapide
c'était super pas rapide il fallait
entre 15 et 20 minutes de téléchargement
juste pour un titre un titre c'est long
et si la connexion échoué pendant le
téléchargement ce qui arrivé très
souvent
ben fallait tout recommencer le pirate à
l'époque ça se mérite et surtout que les
forfaits internet en 1999 avec 1 56 cas
n'était pas illimitée cinquante heures
d'internet par mois et qu'ils étaient
contents c'est pour ça que céline dion
ça n'aurait pas été mon premier choix
est ce que vous savez ce que vous
risquez en faisant ça pas vraiment pas
du tout même
deux ans de prison et un million de
francs d'amendé quand même mais encore
faut-il attraper les gens qui
téléchargent et qui gravent d aider
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment de
commettre d'une certaine manière un vol
en faisant ça je persiste à dire que je
trouve que le prix d'un cd est beaucoup
trop chère par rapport à la part que
prend l'artiste aidé à part que prend la
maison de disques s'il y avait un juste
milieu que l'artiste gagner autant que
la maison de disque là
il faudrait encore réfléchir mais je
pense que ça changerait pas mal de
choses elle près du cdb serait pas de
moitié mais pas loin malgré la sanction
possible vous allez continuer ah oui ça
c'est sûr et certain
sans problème vincent une sorte de robin
des bois de la musique je vole pour
redistribuer à moi même c'est vrai faut
bien avouer qu'à cette époque il y avait
un petit côté magie on découvrait
internet et ce nouveau monde connecté
tout était à portée de main sans bouger
de la maison on pouvait télécharger
toutes les musiques que l'on voulait en
gros c'est comme si on offrait la fnac
on savait un petit peu que c'était
illégal mais la plupart du temps nous
voiler la face
c'était tellement facile et puis c'est à
la maison qu'ils pouvaient savoir qu'ils
télécharger quoi qui faisait quoi voilà
le succès de napster et du piratage
était telle que dans certaines
universités le réseau était saturé
tellement ça télécharger toute
l'industrie du disque tremble devant ces
jeunes sociétés rebelles qui envahissent
internet les ventes de cd baissent déjà
et il est prévu qu'en 2005 10 % de la
musique soient vendus sur le net
et ça ce n'est pas une bonne nouvelle
pour tout le monde pour ce qui est de 2
nous on compte sur vous pour nous
trouver
il a pris la drogue alain et ouais à
partir des années 2000 ça a été le début
de la fin des grandes maisons de disques
qui arrivait à limiter la casse côté
piratage elle n'avait pas vu débarquer
le mp3 et internet
c'est ballot des millions de manque à
gagner un véritable pillage
aujourd'hui c'est 13 millions de pirates
à rien qu'en france 2,5 milliards de
contenus consommés illégalement deux ans
à peine après le lancement de napster en
juillet 2001 le logiciel est retiré la
justice américaine l'interdît pour
infraction à la législation sur le droit
d'auteur mais le mal est fait la voix
est ouvert et on voit l'apparition de
nombreux programmes comme nous tels la
muse limewire pendant sa courte vie le
napster inégale a compté jusqu'à 50
millions d'utilisateurs dans le monde
après parce que maintenant fait napster
il est devenu légal je crois qu'ils ont
gardé le nom surtout dans les années
2000 les connexions internet sont de
plus en plus rapide après le mp3 pour la
musique on voit apparaître de nouveaux
formats le mp4
cette fois ci pour la vidéo
et déjà les premiers films sont
disponibles sur internet
ces nouvelles technologies soulève de
nombreuses questions
faudra-t-il demain à redéfinir la notion
de droits d'auteur la création est elle
vraiment en danger ou saura-t-elle
s'adapter comme elle l'a toujours fait
[Musique]